I have a confession I have been in an
affair since I was 17 years old I wish I
could talk about butterflies in my
stomach or maps I do on the ground when
I think about this affair but I cannot I
wish I could talk about sweet words
spoken or gifts that I received from
this affair but I cannot all I can tell
you about is the aftermath about days I
spent constantly asking why why oh why
me I remember how it all began as in my
final year of high school and my class
had just won in the spot so we were
singing and dancing and hugging each
other I went and took a shower then I
went for dinner and when I sat down to
eat my teeth started chattering and so I
couldn't put the spoon in my mouth
and I rushed to the nurse's office and
because I couldn't talk I just pointed
at my mouth and she didn't know what was
happening so she told me to lie down and
it was after a few minutes the
chattering stopped and I was about to
dash out and she told me no she insisted
that I go up to the Dhamma trees to slip
yeah I was in my final year of high
school just a few months from doing my
end of high school exams and a few days
from doing a set of exams we call here
in Kenya MOOCs which are somehow meant
to gauge how prepared one is for the
final exams there is no way I was going
to sleep and let a set of exams mock me
I went to class sat down took my Kenyan
his frindle
and there was down Kennon coastal town
with the grace makutsi Lily one Enza the
grammar woman who led her people against
British colonial rule then without any
notice my left hand started jacking and
it was a simple mark in imaginary papers
and in and out it went and with every
stroke one by one my classmate stopped
concentrating on their reading and
started looking at me and I tried really
hard to stop it but it couldn't because
it had a life of its own and then when
it was sure everybody was looking at us
in his final show and official
introduction I had my first full-blown
seizure which was the beginning of what
has been a fifteen year long affair
seizures are the trademark
characteristic for most types of
epilepsy and every first ever seizure
needs to be assessed by a doctor to
determine if one has epilepsy or it is a
symptom of something else in my case it
was confirmed that I have epilepsy
I spend a large chunk of my time in
hospital and at home and it only went
back to do my final exams I had seizures
in between peoples but managed to get
good enough grades to be admitted for an
actuarial science degree at the
University of Nairobi
[Applause]
unfortunately I had to drop out in my
second year I didn't have good enough
cooking skills and a support community
around me I was lucky enough to get a
job but I was fired from that job when I
had a seizure in the workplace so I
found myself in a space where I was
constantly asking myself why this had to
happen to me and I lived in denial for a
long time and the denial was maybe
because of the things that had happened
dropping out of school and being fired
from a job or maybe it was because of
the things I had had about epilepsy and
about people living with epilepsy that
they would never live on their own that
I would never travel on their owner or
even get work that they were outcasts
with a spirit in them that they needed
to be delivered from and so the more I
thought about these things the more my
seizures become became and I spent days
with my legs locked and my speech became
blood and on days on end
this is how it be two or three days
after a seizure my head and my hands
would still be twitching I felt lost
like I'd lost everything and sometimes
even the will to live
has so much frustration in me and so I
started writing because the people
around me didn't have answers to the
questions that I had and so I wrote my
peers and my doubts and I wrote about my
good days and my bad days and my really
ugly days and I shared them on a blog
and before long I did rally to be seen
and had by people who had epilepsy and
their families and even those who did
not have the diagnosis and I moved from
that girl who constantly asked why me to
one who not only self advocates but does
it for those who are yet to find their
voices
my seizures of greatly reduced from two
to three times a day - sometimes two to
three times in one year I went on I went
on to employ five people when I began
what was Kenya's first free mental
health and epilepsy support line and I
travel and I travel to speak about my
affair all these things that I have been
told people like me living with epilepsy
could never be able to do every year a
population as big as 80% of Nairobi gets
diagnosed with epilepsy across the globe
and they like me go through them the
motions of stigma and exclusion and so I
have made it my life's journey to keep
this conversations going and I keep
conception about my affair so that those
people who do not have the diagnosis my
know and might have a constant reminder
that it is alright to engage with people
like us that as long as they pull down
the walls of stigma and exclusion that
we just like them can be able to take
anything life throws at us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]